oberlandesgericht hamburg vor gericht
steht die 35 jährige deutsche
staatsangehörige oma emma im januar 2015
soll sie sich dem s angeschlossen haben
mit ihren drei kleinen kindern habe sie
bis 2016 hk gelebt und sich
eingegliedert in die strukturen der
terrorgruppe
als ehefrau von kämpfern dieser
vereinigung sollte ihre kinder im geiste
der vereinigung erzogen haben und sich
auch an der fast klage eines 13 jahre
alten jüdischen mädchens beteiligt haben
darüber hinaus besteht der verdacht dass
sie eine schusswaffe marke kalaschnikow
besessen hat und über das internet
propaganda der vereinigung verbreitet
hat oma emma war die frau des wohl
bekanntesten deutschen es terroristen
dennis kasper der einstige rapper deso
dogg auf und kommt kommt zum jahr 2018
starb bei einem drohnen angriff schon
2016 kehrte oma iaa mit den kindern nach
deutschland zurück und lebte in hamburg
lange unentdeckt von den behörden am 9
september 2009 10 wird sie verhaftet
der vorwurf mitgliedschaft in einer
terroristischen mitteln
ich persönlich glaube eigentlich nicht
dass wenn man es sauber subsumiert
rechtlich in den mitgliedstaaten das
letztlich jede frau eines kämpfers
mittlerweile als mitglied dieser
vereinigung angesehen wird der prozess
in hamburg wird dauern
die angeklagte schweigt all hall in
syrien vor wenigen wochen seit dem ende
des kalifats sitzen tausende frauen von
ehemaligen kämpfern in haft oder
verstecken sich darunter auch viele
deutsche wie maria
2014 folgte mariam ihrem mann zum es
heute gibt sie sich ruhig
dieser ganze ab schlachterei das
zurschaustellen von leichen
warum bindet man eine leiche oder einen
sterbenden menschen an ein auto und
fährt mit ihm noch über einen
schotterweg und kinder und frauen haben
dabei zugeschaut
für mich sind das einfach unmenschen
derzeit versteckt sich maria mal vor
ihrem ehemaligen komplizen
sie erzählt jeder habe sehen können wie
der e s menschen terrorisiert habe und
der terror gehe selbst nach der
niederlage in den gefangenenlagern
weiter dort herrschten fanatische es
anhängerinnen
ein mädchen wurde von ihrer eigenen
großmutter dort umgebracht weil sie sich
nicht mehr bis zu den augen verschleiern
wollte also da sind wirklich noch viele
hardliner viele von ihnen ausländer
manche kämpfen eine frau hat sich bei
idlib in die luft gesprengt
welche rolle spielten die frauen beim es
offenbar eine größere als die sorgsame
ehefrauen und mütter
frühjahr 2009 10 die schlachtung bacchus
in syrien
diese amateuraufnahmen zeigen frauen
kämpfen an der front als die schlacht
verloren scheint ergeben sich viele den
kurden und schülern darunter auch eine
deutsche hilfe zu bitten für mich jetzt
großartiges gemacht außerhalb die frauen
geholfen reparaturen erledigt als büros
war erhalten also mehr hat er nicht
getan
erste zurzeit verletzter angeschossen
nicht beim kampf sondern heißt es beim
hilfe beim helfen mir meine sachen zu
packen
diese kundin war bei der verhaftung
dabei ihren vollen namen können wir aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht nennen
und im bacchus da waren ja nur noch die
gs kämpfer übrig die gekämpft haben um
den stadtteil
also stimmt das auch nicht was die uns
die ganze zeit erzählt haben die haben
alle das gleiche erzählt ich glaube dass
wurde da abgemacht bevor die sich
ergeben haben an unsere leute dass dir
das alles so sagen das team auch frei
kommen vielleicht doch zeugen wie diese
kunden kommen vor deutschen gerichten
selten zu wort
natürlich haben die us frauen gesagt
dass sie nichts gemacht haben nichts
gehört haben und das alles aber die er
zusammen mit den sklaven gelebt haben
dass er alles mitgekriegt was mit denen
passiert melissa konnte es frauen filmen
die sklavenhaltung rechtfertigten
ich kenne zum beispiel eines klage
mein bruder hat drei frauen und eines
klar ich habe nicht das
oberlandesgericht düsseldorf im dezember
2009 10 wurde minicar verurteilt drei
jahre und neun monate haft
sie führte den haushalt eines deutschen
des kämpfers ihres mannes und bekam
dafür monatliche zahlungen vom es laut
urteil war sie beteiligt an
kriegsverbrechen wohnungs plünderungen
nach dem tod ihres mannes wurde sie in
der türkei verhaftet
auch mini paradis erkennt in den
terrorstaat mitgenommen doch das spielte
beim strafmaß kaum eine rolle
ja bei monika ist mir aufgefallen dass
sie das kind ja in ein kriegsgebiet
gebracht hat aber keinerlei reue
darüber zeigt der ct auch sagen können
ich tausche mich darüber wie die
zustände dort sind aber nachdem sie die
zustände dort gesehen hat hat sie auch
noch keinerlei reue und hatten viel mehr
das kind später hing benutzt um sich
sozusagen als opfer dieser ganzen
handlungen darstellen
martin ja ja heising und serkan alkan
sind die verteidiger von minicar und
anderen es rückkehrerinnen die anwälte
haben revision gegen das urteil
eingelegt
das sind es mädchen die im
pubertierenden alter irgendwo zum islam
gefunden haben den islam als eine pop
kultur wahrgenommen haben sich im
internet informiert haben warmuth
youtube youtube gelandet sind es der
eine durchgangsstation gewesen ist die
fan darunter mit irgendwelchen archiven
erwartungen
haben dort ein böses erwachen kommen
zurück und sind meistens ganz normal
insofern denke ich wenn wir jetzt da den
vergleich tätigen zwischen
kriegsverbrecher verfahren
terrorismus-verfahren raf verfahren nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg das mit der sache
nicht gerecht
das urteil gegen mine cover der
bundesgerichtshof prüfen und entscheiden
ob die verurteilung nach
völkerstrafgesetzbuch bestand hat bis
heute behauptet minicar nur ehefrau
eines kämpfers gewesen zu sein
also für mich sind das keine opfer weil
manchmal in europa werden die es frauen
als opfer dargestellt oder als kinder
weise sehr jungen dorthin gegangen sind
was meiner meinung gar nicht richtig ist
maria meyer indes plant ihre rückkehr
nach deutschland die prozesse in
deutschland hat sie von syrien aus über
das internet verfolgt zu hause will sie
sich einem gericht stellen
ich kann den leuten nicht irgendwie die
schuld für meine fehler geben weder
meinem ex-mann noch meiner mutter oder
meiner familie oder sonst wem also es
liegt immer an einem seht das wieder
hingegangen sind
[Musik]